I'm not making a run for the White House
but I do have a plan to cover at least
half of the 45 million Americans who
need health insurance hi I'm Nick
Gillespie the candidates won't talk
about my plan because they're too scared
to talk straight about one of the most
emotional issues on the campaign trail
to tell the kids growing taller every
day in this video of family copes with
the sudden illness of a little girl
named II got a bruise that wouldn't go
away and is forced to sell the family
home to pay the medical bills I am the
captain of a health insurers company
sometimes the mood is light-hearted like
depicting insurance company execs as
plundering pirates but the underlying
message is always heavy
old people and families are being abused
by our health care system the candidates
have made reform a top priority bold
solutions for America's health care mess
I will sign a universal health care plan
into law while the candidates duel over
who's got the best plan they ignore the
easiest solution my solution call it the
gillespie plan if you want health
insurance get some I was gonna get
health insurance that I got drunk his
buddy doesn't have insurance either his
employer offered it but they're taking
too much out of my paycheck for it so if
they take the money out of my paycheck
for health insurance I won't have enough
to make rent we found these guys on la's
famous Sunset Strip well more like a
back alley near the string don't expect
to see them featured a new campaign by
Anthony Upsy on my knuckles like sticks
out about half an inch above where's my
hand they don't quite pull at the
heartstrings like a sick little girl but
don't young musicians deserve insurance
too it'd be nice to have health
insurance once in a while he says he has
to choose between housing and health so
i'll just be living on the street so
it's like a what do you want you want a
house or do you want to be healthy this
guy says he's in the same boat because
coverage is simply out of reach that's
one luxury I can't afford them because I
have to eat and have ran you know I mean
isn't there some way they could get
covered it probably cost him around a
hundred dollars per month to buy
insurance way too much for someone on
the verge of homelessness then again how
much does this guy spend on partying
at least yeah yeah whatever I couldn't
get my hands on where does his money go
I workout supplements and stuff cost me
like three hundred dollars a month
vitamins protein God you don't I mean
it's very clear that that guy would be
able to afford into health insurance if
you really wanted to dr. Glenn Whitman
is an economist at Cal State Northridge
you might not get as much protein powder
but he might get more of what he really
needs the medicines and treatments that
he needs to help him live longer ah but
who wants to give up properly pumped
pence or a cool wardrobe this guy
doesn't have insurance I I do split a
lot of money on like clothes stuff like
that my black man we spent a lot of
money on clothes if he spent less on
clothes could he buy insurance that's
not gonna happen i'm gonna go to the
free clinics that look good that's what
I'm gonna do I might be sick inside I'm
look good on outside how come
politicians never talk about guys like
him the reason people don't have health
insurance isn't because they don't want
it it's because they can't afford it
affordable affordable affordable health
care for all so health care must be made
affordable affordable is very difficult
thing to define there are those who
really can't afford health insurance and
there are those who can't afford it and
simply choose not to buy it because they
want to buy something else people who
could buy coverage but don't we used to
hearing about the most sympathetic
stories children families single moms
everywhere I go single moms trying to
figure out how are they gonna get health
care for their families but come on
folks on the Sunset Strip aren't the
same as regular American
well actually they're more
representative than you might think
although too many families and children
are suffering most uninsured people
don't have kids they're generally young
relatively healthy adults with fewer
grown-up responsibilities so folks like
these shouldn't be our only image of the
uninsured because they're more likely to
look like these guys and like our Sunset
Strip crew a surprising number of the
uninsured could get coverage if they
wanted so people currently classified as
uninsured conservative estimate says
about forty five percent of them would
be able to get health insurance right
now if they wanted it that estimate
comes from a study headed by a scholar
from Johns Hopkins University which says
that those who could get covered if they
wanted to fall into one of two
categories people who either could
afford to buy health insurance with
their current income or already qualify
for some form of government assistance
in the form of Medicaid or s CHIP
programs like that s chip covers kids
and medicaid covers the poor another
program medicare covers folks over 65 so
although the system needs reform it's
not exactly giving seniors a boot in the
butt eleven million Americans qualify
for existing government programs but
they just don't sign up for them why not
it might mean they are embarrassed to
take advantage of it or that they don't
know that the program is available to
them of course most campaign speeches
focus on cost so my commitment is to
make sure that we bring the costs of
health insurance down costs do seem to
be shooting up higher all the time and
there are plenty of sensible things
politicians could do about that
but remember nearly half the uninsured
could be covered and the real figure is
almost certainly higher a lot of people
out there that choose to buy a lot of
things that they can't afford them the
Johns Hopkins study looked at how much
money people make families earning less
than 58,000 dollars per year were
considered too poor to afford health
insurance what the study didn't look at
is all the other things they spend money
on more than a thousand bucks each year
on telephone services according to the
bureau of labor statistics alcohol more
than 400 bucks cigarettes personal care
products clothes eating out well it's
going to eat we know my man over here
spit a lot you know I spend less xmen
passes will we spend if millions to get
insurance without any more help from
Washington why don't the candidates urge
them to get covered tonto politicians
aren't in the business of telling us
what we need to hear they're in the
business of telling us what we want to
do you're not going to get as many votes
telling people you need to change your
life you need to fix your problems on
your own as you're going to get saying
to people we're going to solve all of
your problems for you the issue is that
not every problem has a political
solution could a president McCain get
these guys to care less about partying
could a president obama get this guy to
spend less on protein powder could
either get him to care less about
clothes forget him to care it all he
says he makes enough money to buy
insurance but nothing's gonna happen to
me bro I'm the luckiest guy in America
so how about some real straight talk for
a change if we separate those who truly
can't get coverage from those who can we
can focus more on helping the needy so
if you can get coverage don't wait for
Washington go out and get some go on for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you